Hello everyone. Welcome to a new episode of The
Dissenter. I'm your host, as always, Richard Lops, and
today I'm joined by Dr. Harry Ray. He is
Dean's Professor in Arts and Sciences and professor of
psychology at the University of Rochester. And today we're
going to talk about his book which he wrote
together with Dr. Sonia Lebomirsky of the title of
it is How to Feel Love, The Five Mindsets
that Get You More of What Matters Most. So
Dr. Roy, welcome to the show. It's a pleasure
for everyone.
It's, it's great to be here, Ricardo.
So let me start by asking you a few
basic questions that maybe many people just, they take
the answer for granted, but maybe as a psychologist
you approach it in a or approach them in
a slightly different way. So what is love? I
mean, what, how do you understand that?
Well, love is actually one of the trickiest words
we have in, in not just the English language,
but in all of our languages. Love can mean
so many different things, you know, you can talk
about loving a television show, you can talk about
loving your mother, you can talk about loving an
afternoon when you don't have any work obligations, and
of course you can talk about loving somebody that
uh you're in a romantic relationship with. Um, SO,
you know, that, that being the case, we felt
the need to be very clear about what we
mean by love. And what we mean by love
is, is a feeling of warmth and compassion toward
another person, a feeling that um the other person
is somebody who you deeply admire, deeply respect, and
feel a great deal of compassion for.
And what is it to feel loved? I mean,
what, what does that translate to translate into exactly?
I mean, what is it that people feel loved?
Yeah,
well, you know, that's actually a kind of a
tricky question to answer because feeling loved is one
of those things. That people can't necessarily verbalize what
they mean by feeling loved. I, uh, when you
feel loved, you know it. And if you ask
people, um, do you feel loved, people can tell
you, I feel loved, I don't feel loved, um,
but if you ask them, well, what do you
mean by that, you know, that's something that philosophers
like to do, of course, um, if you ask
someone what they mean by feeling loved, it's a
sense that another person gets you. Um, THEN another
person really understands what you're all about. Um, THAT
they respect and admire you, and especially that you
feel that they are concerned for your well-being, that
they care how things go for you, that they
have compassion, uh, for you, and, um, that, and
that they're essentially on your side.
And is feeling love a human need? I mean,
is it necessarily that everyone needs to feel loved?
Well, we certainly feel that that is the case,
um, to be sure. There are individuals who tell
you they don't need to feel loved, um, and
we see that as, as a reaction to the
circumstances that they may have grown up with or
they may have experienced, um, but, but we see
the, the, the need to feel loved as really
as very important because it's the mental part that
goes along with, um, with, with connection and belonging.
And there's, there's a lot of work to suggest
that um humans almost without exception, have a strong
need to belong. Um, OVER our evolutionary history, this
is one of the things that has really um
helped our species survive, you know, if you, you
know, think about a newborn baby, um, if a
newborn baby did not have other people to care
for it and to protect it, it would have
no chance of surviving. And, and that's true for
quite a long period of time, um, and as
we get older, then the nature of that need
changes, but it is no less important, so adults
who don't feel a need to connect with others,
who don't feel a sense of belonging, tend to
not do very well, and there's lots of interesting
research that shows that uh when people have strong
social connection, they live longer, they're happier. Um, THEY
do better, they, they, they, they do better in
school or in work, um, and so, you know,
the, the, the need to connect with others is,
is really an essential human component, and the sense
of feeling loved is the way that we tell
ourselves that are, that we are that we are
connected, that we do have a belonging with other
people.
So you would say that this need there's an
evolutionary basis to it.
I would absolutely say that there's an evolutionary basis,
and I, that's a fairly widespread idea that I
think um most people, most scientists would accept that
idea.
Mhm. But I mean, the way that we feel
loved, I mean, and what that means to us,
do you think that it depends a little bit
on our own personal experiences and this is something
that we develop
through our lives? Well, uh, you know, that that's,
that's a great and very important point. Uh, THE
way the need to feel loved comes out. Um,
IS definitely a function of our experience, you know,
for some people, feeling loved is about having a
few distant connections, um, and some people you can
hang out with, um, but not a really strong
sense of, you know, that deep emotional kind of
feeling. For other people, it's very much about having
warm, strong connections with many other people. Um, AND
it, you know, for some people it might be,
um, having a really strong connection with a single
partner, with, with, you know, with a, with a
primary partner. For other people it might be more
of being part of a social network where you
are connecting with a lot of people. I think
it comes out differently for different people. We know
that early experiences play a role in shaping that.
Um, THERE are probably other factors that contribute as
well that aren't so well understood. So, so there
are big individual differences and differences in the way
that need plays out, but underlying all of it,
the sort of common core to it, is, is,
is this need to feel that like one is
connected to others and that there are others who
are concerned, uh, for one's welfare. You know, you,
you, you could make an analogy to hunger. We,
we all have a need to eat. Uh, FOR
some people that means, you know, having a steak
and potatoes every night. For other people that might
mean eating vegetables. For still other people, it might
mean, you know, snacking during the day. So the
way the need to eat and fulfill one's hunger
comes out is different, but underlying all of it
is the need to take in calories, and we
think it's the same kind of thing for the
need to belong.
And when it comes to those individual differences, I
would imagine that some of it would also have
to do with maybe personality traits, right? Like, like,
like for example, introversion, extroversion, things like that. Yes,
absolutely. Individual differences would would play a huge part.
You know, individual differences, they have genetic roots, uh,
their early experience plays a huge role. For an
introverted person, it might be a matter of having
a small number of friends that you can spend
quiet nights together with. For a more gregarious person,
it could be, you know, being able to go
to lots of parties, um, and, you know, make,
make, making lots of noise, um, so I, I
think there are lots of different ways that the
need can, can play out, um, but underlying all
of it is that we all have this need
to connect in, in, in one form or another.
And what might be the costs, I mean, the
psychological costs and consequences of not feeling loved?
Well, not, not feeling loved has, has lots of
consequences. It, it, it's, it's certainly linked to being
unhappy, um, it's certainly linked to having a more
difficult time accomplishing the many things that go on
in life. There's, there's very nice research showing that,
um, it leads people to adopt unhealthy habits, um,
and it's associated with uh premature death, in fact,
um, um, and, Uh, there's recently been research that
shows that uh people who don't have strong social
connections, uh, that the risk factors to dying prematurely
are actually greater than the risk of dying prematurely
due to things like smoking and obesity. Um, SO
that's certainly very powerful, but more generally it, it,
it simply creates a sense that one's life is
not going the way that one wants, and it,
it. It can create, it can create depression, it
can certainly create loneliness, um, it can create a
sense of what we might call quiet desperation, um,
but it, it, it really, um, it creates a
sense of not being fulfilled and not feeling like,
like, um, life is valuable and enjoyable.
Uh, IN the way that it can connect to
the sense of feeling lonely. I mean, when and
how do people feel lonely, because, and please correct
me if I'm wrong, but in my understanding, uh,
being alone or spending time alone or even for
more introverted people spending lots of time alone is
not the same thing as feeling lonely.
Right, right, well, I, I, I want to make
a strong case for the idea that loneliness. In
and of itself is not necessarily a, a negative
emotion. Um, WHEN people feel loneliness exists because it
serves a function. When people feel lonely, what many
of us do is we go out and we
create a connection. I feel lonely tonight. I think
I'll call up my friend. I, I think I'll,
I'll go, I'll go to the, the gym and
talk to people there. Um, I think I'll go
on a date. I think I'll call my family
that lives in another city. Loneliness is a, is
a way of our bodies and minds telling us
that our social connection is not as good as
we would like it to be, and when it
stimulates going out and doing something about it, it's
a very positive emotion. It's a constructive emotion. Where
loneliness gets problematic. Is when it's chronic or long
standing when the per a person feels lonely often.
Um, CONTINUOUSLY and doesn't really have a strategy to
deal with it, uh, when, when that kind of
loneliness becomes chronic, that's when it starts to be
a problem. Um, THAT'S when it creates difficulties for
people, and loneliness over the long term is associated
with just about everything bad that you can think
of, uh, ranging from a higher incidence of cancer,
higher incidence of heart disease. A higher incidence of
depression and suicide, just about everything that that we
can think of that's unhealthy and unproductive is associated
with long-term chronic loneliness, but I really want to
stress the point that if one feels lonely because
one just moved to a new city. Or because
none of one's friends are available to go out
on Saturday night, that's not necessarily pathological, and that
in fact that can be a very constructive emotion.
Yeah, so it's problematic when it's really chronic,
when it's chronic, um, and, and, and also especially
when the person blames themselves for it, um, you
know, you know, you, you can say, why do
I feel lonely? Well, nobody likes me, I'm just
an unlikable person. When that kind of mental state
goes along with the feeling of loneliness, that's when
we see all these kind of problems.
And uh, I mean, people recently have been talking
a lot about the so-called loneliness epidemic. I mean,
what is your understanding of that? Do you think
that it's really an epidemic or?
Well, um, you know, if I, if I take
a purely empirical stance on this, uh, levels of
loneliness are now higher than they've ever been since,
uh, such data were, were being kept. Um, NOW
that only goes back a relatively small number of
years. So are people lonely lonelier now than they
were in the 1600s? I have no idea. Um,
BUT certainly over the past 50 years or so,
uh, we've seen loneliness increase. In fact, in my
classes, I, I've, I ask people questions about loneliness,
and over the last few years, the level of
loneliness is higher than it's ever been, um, and
that goes back about 25 or 30 years. Um.
The question of where that comes from is an
interesting and difficult one. There are many people who
would like to blame social media for it. Um,
AND undoubtedly social media are a factor in it,
you know, the idea there is that when people
spend their time on social media, it, it's kind
of a way of snacking with with social connection,
but it, it's not really fulfilling. It's not a
deep sense of, of connection, and so the more
time one spends on social media and stays away
from face to face interaction. Uh, THE more likely
one is to be lonely. There was a really
interesting little experiment done in a, in a couple
of school districts in, in the US where what
they did was, uh, uh, they took students' phones
away from them during the school day. So at
lunchtime, um, in the cafeteria, instead of spending time
scrolling, they're actually talking to each other, um, and,
and that was associated with a greater sense of
well-being. Now do I think social media is the
only reason for greater loneliness? No, I think that
would be kind of, that would be kind of
simplistic. There are many other reasons why, um, I
think, you know, there's evidence that people are not
joining organizations, um, as much as they used to
because, you know, staying home and, and streaming television.
Is uh very comfortable and very easy, um, and
instead of, you know, going out and doing things
with other people, there's more and more, uh, fulfillment
that you can get, uh, by yourself, uh, staying
home. I think that's probably a contributing factor. Some
of the sense of alienation that people have, um,
in, in, in our, um, cultures, you know, politically
speaking, there's more and more of a sense of
us, them. Um, GOING on, and that contributes to
people not feeling part of their community. So I
think it's multifaceted, um. But, you know, what's kind
of interesting about it is that attacking the root
causes of all these different things may be kind
of challenging, but the advice that you can give
people about what to do about this if they
feel lonely is actually kind of easy. Go out
and do something with other people. It's as simple
as that, um, join a club, go to, go
to a restaurant or a bar with friends, um,
go to a church, um, join some organization, um,
simply go out and socialize with other people is
the first recommendation that that anyone would make, and
it's usually effective.
Do you think that perhaps another factor that might
have been playing a role here when it comes
to loneliness would have to do with the way
we've been organizing our cities, and I'm talking about
cities because those are the places where a majority
of the population lives in today, but we've been
Organizing our cities in a way that there's fewer
and fewer public spaces where people can easily meet
without having to, uh, I mean, spend money, I
mean without having to go to, I don't know,
the cafes, restaurants, the shopping, or elsewhere, where they
actually You have to spend money to be with
other people and I mean, adding to that, the
way that the economy is right now, maybe that
makes some people feel a little bit of shame,
I imagine. Uh, I, I, I don't know if
shame is exactly the word that I would use,
but I think certainly the way cities organize themselves
is undoubtedly a fact. You know, I, I was
in Scotland last week. And um at one night
we went out to a bar and the bar
was jammed with people of all different ages, all
different uh socioeconomic uh strata as far as I
could tell, um, and there was um Scottish folk
music playing and people were talking to each other,
not necessarily to the friends that they had come
with, and there was a real sense of community
to this. Um, YOU don't see that kind of
thing in the US very much, um, and, and
I think that the way that our social life
has been organized has, uh, kind of locked us
into our, um, into our shells. Um, ONE of
my colleagues, uh, Nick Epley at the University of
Chicago, has done a whole series of fascinating studies
where he gives people the instruction. Um, TO talk
to somebody on the subway trains. Now on subway
trains, um, people don't talk to each other. Everyone's
kind of locked into their shell, and if, and
if you say to me, why don't you talk
to the person next to you, they'll say, well,
they don't want to really talk to me. Nobody
wants that kind of. So, but he gave them
the instruction, he told them to do it, and
you know what, people enjoy it. People like it.
They, they report, uh, that, that it makes them
feel good. Um, SO in the in urban life,
because of the kind of crowding and because of
the way things are organized, we tend to lock
ourselves into these little boxes, and if we go
out of our way to make connections with other
people, uh, that often increases people's well-being.
Mhm. Uh, BUT earlier when you mentioned social media
and said that it's basically people snacking on connection
and it doesn't really serve as real connection, what
makes for real connection between people?
Real Real connection comes from conversation with other people,
um, preferably in person, um. When people are in
the, there's, um, we don't know exactly what is
going on, but there are physiological processes that are
triggered when people are socializing with other people. Face
to face interaction, typically involving conversation with other people.
Is what gets those needs fulfilled, and I want
to be clear that I'm not just talking about,
you know, deep empathic conversations. Those are great, and
we'll probably get to talking about those, um, but
I'm talking about simply ordinary conversations about the World
Cup, about, about the weather, about all the little
things that go on in our life. Any kind
of connection like that is the beginning. Uh, TO,
uh, you know, fulfilling this need to connect that
we all have.
Mhm. Uh, IN the book, you go through several
different beliefs that are very common among people and
that, uh, and contrast them with the, with what
the science actually says about what makes one feel
loved, and I think it's Very important for us
to go through each of the five if only
beliefs as you call them in the book, uh,
to go through all of them because I think
that maybe many people are not even aware that
they actually have those beliefs and The consequences that
they might have for their lives. So the first
one is, if only I were more attractive, powerful,
or successful, I would feel more loved. So what
does the science actually says about?
OK, so, so now we're talking about the sort
of deeper connections that come when one feels like
another person really values and understands and cares about
you. Um, PEOPLE have all kinds of beliefs about
where, about, you know, what to do and all
that, and one of the strongest beliefs we have,
and this I think is especially true in, in
the Western world, is the idea that if I
was more attractive, if I was more accomplished, if
I had achieved more, other people would love me,
uh, would love me more, um. You know, it's
instructive to think, uh, when was the last time
you walked through a cemetery and you saw on
somebody's gravestone, I was beautiful and powerful. You know
that what people write is, you know, things about
loving and being beloved. Feeling how you're being, letting
other people know that one is attractive or powerful
or accomplished. It may make other people admire you.
It may make other people think, wow, you know,
that, that person, you know, he's really something, but
it doesn't make them want to connect with you.
In fact, it can often make them not want
to connect with you because they're kind of intimidated
by you. Um, SO, and I think it's kind
of ironic that if you look at, um, so
at people's postings on, uh, online dating services. They
often stress, you know, oh, I, you know, I'm
such a powerful person, or, and they put out
a picture that makes them look really gorgeous. Well,
that, you know, that may attract likes, uh, but
it doesn't create the kind of warm, warm, strong
connection, um, that people really need to feel loved
and connected to another person.
Uh, AND then there are two, if only beliefs
that I think go more or less together. One
has to do with, oh, if only people knew
more about my positive qualities and successes, or if
I could make sure that they knew about that,
I would feel more loved than the other one
is if I could only hide my shortcomings, I
would feel. More love. So I mean, it's people,
basically people's fear of resenting their negative aspects and
people not knowing enough about their positive qualities. So
what does the science say
about? Yeah, yeah, you know, that it's really great
of you to put them together. You know, many
people believe that in order to make a good
impression on other people, you have to stress all
the positive and wonderful traits you have and you
have to hide your shortcomings, um, and you know
what the research actually says is that as long
as you're hiding your shortcomings, you can't feel really
known because what, what will go on in people's
mind is, well, You know, if, if they knew
blank about me, then they probably wouldn't like me
so much, so I'm going to hide that. And
so the irony is, you know, feeling known is,
is an essential component that underlies feeling loved. You
have to feel like other people know the real
true you, and the real true you includes the
shortcomings you have. It includes the things that you
don't do particularly well. It includes the things you
might be embarrassed about, um, and, and until you
feel that other people know those things and still
love you, that's when you can feel really, that's
when you can begin to develop a sense of
feeling loved. Until that happens, you're always going to
feel like there's a wall between you and other
people, um, when they find out that I. You
know, uh, you know, that I, that I'm messy
when they find out that, um. Uh, I really
can be rude and nasty at times. When they
find those things out, that's going to turn them
off. Until we can get past those things and
make sure the other person knows those shortcomings, uh,
there's little chance of, of feeling truly known and
loved.
Do you think that there's, that has anything to
do with people's fear of rejection or of being
rejected by particular people?
I think that's exactly right. Uh, PEOPLE feel that
when they find out blank about me, that that's
going to be the end of it, you know,
this is especially true when people have, um, Committed
some kind of terrible transgression earlier in their past,
um, they feel like, well, if you find out
that I did this, um, then, you know, that's
going to be going to be the end. One
of the, the stories that we tell in the
book that I think is so compelling is the
story of a, of a man who lived in
Australia, lived a long life, um, when he died,
he left a letter for his wife and children.
That explained that when he was a teenager, he
had murdered his parents. Um, NOW he had managed
to get away, get to not be caught from
this, and he had left the country, changed his
name, and moved to Australia, but he obviously harbored
these terrible feelings inside himself, and he was, and
why did he not tell his wife this while
he was alive? Well, he probably was afraid that
that would turn her off and make her reject
him, um, but at the same time, his need
to tell her. Um, WAS so strong that he
left her this note. There, there's a website that,
um, listeners might find interesting. It, it's, um, it's
called Frank Warren's Postscript, and it's a, it's a
website where people can write in. Um, AND, and
anonymously post, terrible things that they've done in their
life, and, and you look at the list of
things and you know, the range of things that
people are afraid to tell others in their life,
but yet that they're itching to get out is
really kind of quite remarkable.
Mhm. There's also this belief that, oh, if only
my partner could speak my love language, I would
feel more loved. I mean, this, this idea of
love languages, does it have any scientific validity?
Uh, YOU know, the, the love languages idea is
very, very popular. Uh, I, I, I heard somebody
saying the other day, um, to their partner, well,
if you only spoke my love language, we'd get
along better. Um, YOU know, the idea of love
languages is that there are certain ways of expressing
love that we all are particularly in tuned to.
So for example, physical touch, words of affirmation, um,
acts of service, um. The idea that matching in
love languages is what makes a relationship strong is
simply not an idea that has any scientific merit
at all. There's, uh, you know, when, uh, Chapman
first developed this idea, you know, it was a
reasonable idea. It's one of those ideas that you
hear and you think, oh yes, that makes sense.
Um, AND so, you know, uh, people start to
do that kind of thing, but what the research
has shown is that Matching with somebody on love
languages doesn't really accomplish anything, um, that relationships where
people are matched on love languages do no better
than relationships where people have different love languages, and
in fact, um, really a healthy diet of love
languages is what makes relationships strongest, meaning. Um, WHEN
you can do all of the love languages, um,
that's when relationships are stronger. We all want our
partners to give us words of affirmation. We all
like physical touch. We all appreciate acts of service.
So, you know, instead of thinking, you know, pick
your favorite and that's the one to do, and
you can ignore all the rest, it is really
a recipe for disaster.
Uh, AND finally, if only I could get my
partner to love me more, I would feel more
loved. I mean, what are people really trying to
get with this?
Yes, well, you know, a lot of, I think
that a lot of people approach the question of
feeling more loved. With an idea that it's on
the other person. You need to do something so
I can feel more loved. And, and the problem
with that, and, and we know this from a
great many studies in, in human motivation is trying
to get another person to do something. Is a
recipe for failure, um, you know, you may well
get a certain act out of another person, but
it will typically be, uh, accompanied by resentment. Moreover,
you know, if, if I say, if I say
to my partner, I need you to tell me
that you love me, so my partner says, oh
yes, I love you. Well, that doesn't feel right
because why are they saying it? It's because I
asked them to say it. I don't want to
ask my partner to say it, I want my
partner to spontaneously say it, um, because she wants
to say it, um, so the idea that we
advance in this book is that it's not about
getting another person to do something, it's about creating
the circumstances in which the other person will want
to do something, um, and that's so, and that's
where we introduce. Um, A whole series of mindsets
that we think will create the kinds of interactions
where that kind of feeling will emerge spontaneously from
the back and forth of, of interaction.
Yes, and we'll go through those five mindsets in
a minute, but I mean, it's interesting from what
you said, it seems to me that one interesting
aspect of all of this is that people, what
one of the things at least that people really
want from other people when it comes to feeling
love is authenticity, because I mean, people. Can can
try to fake it in a way till they
make it. I mean fake it till they get
the other person to say that they love them,
but if they know that the way they achieved
it was through faking and it's not authentic, then
they're still bothered by it.
You're absolutely right. Authenticity is really important. There there's
a quote I really love, uh, that is authenticity
is really important, and if you can fake it,
you're in good shape, um, you know, yes, you
can sometimes fake authenticity, but we all have, uh,
you know, internal sensors that tell us when a
person, other person's not being authentic. So unless you're
a really good actor, it's very hard to fake
authenticity, and we want authenticity. Um, YOU know, there
are circumstances in which getting another person to do
something because you asked them to do it is,
is fine, um, but in the long run, and
especially when it comes to feeling loved, we want
that feeling to be authentic. I, I want my
partner to express love for me because she really
feels it, because she really cares about me. Um,
AND that's genuine in her because otherwise it's just
not trustworthy.
But what does it really mean to be yourself,
because I mean that feels really intuitive and right
for people to uh interact with other people as
themselves to, for them to be themselves when establishing
relationships, but what does that really mean?
Right, yeah, um, that, that's a, that's a really
good question, and, and, and here's where we have
to put some nuance in, um, this discussion. Be
yourself doesn't mean that the first time you go
out with somebody, uh, you wear your sloppiest clothes,
you, you know, you, uh, you talk about all
the terrible traumatic feelings and experiences you've had, um,
and you quote unquote, let it all hang out,
you know, that's not what we mean by being
yourself. What we mean by being yourself is that
over time. You let the real you show, so
you, you, you express what your true beliefs are,
you show uh what things you like doing and
what things you don't like doing. Doesn't mean you
can't experiment with trying something the other person likes,
that can actually be very, very constructive, but if
you do something and you don't enjoy it, you,
you know, you, you say it, so. It, it,
it means not putting on a, a, a false
self, not putting on a mask. Um, AND letting
the true you show, um, over, over a period
of time, um, so that the other person knows
what, what you're really all about.
Uh, IN the book you also talk about the
importance of reciprocity in conversation. I mean, why is
that so
important? Well, yeah, well, yeah, here's why, um, opening
up and, and letting the real you show up,
show is so important to feeling loved, um. One
of the arguments we make is that the way
to kick off this process is to be encouraging
and enthusiastic, uh, and expressing love toward the other
person. Now you may say, but wait a minute,
it's not, I don't want to say I love
you, I want you to say I love you.
But one of the ways we do that is
by kicking off the process and expressing those feelings
toward another person, because that often engenders reciprocity. Reciprocity
is one of the strongest rules of social behavior
we have. We all do reciprocity. It's very, very
common. And what we mean by reciprocity is that
it is the exchange good for good, bad for
bad, um, so when I open up, when I
express my feelings for you, when I really listen
carefully to what you have to say, when I
show you that I really have affection and, and
caring and warmth towards you, that often comes back,
and, and the important thing to realize. Is that
I can't control what you do, but I can
control what I do. So if I start the
process by expressing, by expressing warmth and compassion for
you, very often, not 100%, but very often that
will come back towards me. And so that exchange,
that tit for tat kind of process. Is so
important to our conversations, you know, there, there's one
whole line of research that shows that if I
open up about my thoughts and feelings to you
in a constructive way, that will encourage you to
open up, um, and, and so, you know, so
it's important to realize that that's part of the
normal process of social interaction.
In the book, you also talk about this concept
of the relationship seesaw. Uh, COULD you explain it
and why, what kind of understanding can people get
about their relationships from these ideas?
Well, the relationship seesaw is, is the more formal
representation of what we've just been talking about with
reciprocity. Uh, SO think about being on a seesaw,
um, where part of you is submerged, meaning, and
by submerged, what we mean is there are parts
of you that are not seen, and there's parts
of your partner that are submerged and not seen.
If you lift the partner up by listening to
them carefully, by showing enthusiasm for what they're saying,
by showing warmth and compassion for them when they
do open up. What we do is we lift
them up. They will feel good. They will feel
warmth. They will feel like you are really caring
for them. What that does is encourage them to
do the same towards you. So they will in
turn lift you out of the water by listening
to you, by showing enthusiasm for you, by showing
compassion for you, and so it's this back and
forth of I lift you up. You lift me
up and, and, and together we create more uh
connection and love in our relationship, again, not necessarily
in one conversation, but over time.
Mhm. So let's talk now about the five mindsets
then that help us, uh, get the love we
crave and you talk about the sharing mindset, uh,
listening to learn mindset, radical curiosity mindset, and open
heart mindset and the multiplicity mindset. I mean, could
you explain them and, uh, what, uh, what is
the role that these mindsets can play?
Well, you know, we, we might, uh, begin to
talk about this by asking what is, what is
a mindset, you know, a, a mindset is a
mental approach that you use when you're going into
a situation. So when you're going into a conversation
with another person, a mindset is, uh, the, is,
is the mental framework for what am I trying
to do, what am I trying to accomplish, what
do I want to happen. Um, I think it's
easiest to start um with the listening to learn
and curiosity mindsets, um, because those are the ones
that are most directly under your control. The listening
to learn mindset says that you go into a
conversation with the explicit goal of of really listening
to what the other person has to say. This
may sound simple, it's anything but simple. When most
of us are in conversations, we're maybe 20% focused
on what the other person is, is talking about,
and then we're thinking about, you know, what am
I going to say next? Uh, WHERE, where am
I going? Who else is in this room? What
do I have to do tonight, uh. Um, GEE,
you know what color clothes are the people on
the other side of the room wearing? We, we're
thinking about lots of different things and we're not
really focusing in on the other person. Um, THERE'S
a lot of interesting research that documents how poorly
we actually listen to other people, and the importance
of listening is that when you really listen to
the other person, when you really not just pay
attention, but also encourage them to elaborate, ask questions,
you know, one of the strongest things you can
do and one of the simplest things you can
do is when another person tells you something, you
can say, tell me more. Very easy way of.
Saying to them, I'm really interested in what you
have to say, uh, and I really want to
know more about what it means to you. That
goes along with the idea of enthusiasm and curiosity,
showing the other person that you're really curious about
them. You really want to learn what makes them
tick, what are they, you know, what are they
about when they tell you about something that happened
to them last week, when they tell you how
excited they were about, uh, Argentina winning their semi-final
World Cup game, well, you know. What about it
was so exciting to you, um, you know, what
about it was interesting to you, um. That's, that's
a clue. I'm really interested in what you have
to say. So many of us instead will say,
Oh yes, I found that really exciting too, and
then we'll talk about ourselves, and that communicates, I'm
not really interested in what this meant to you.
So you can, so the, the mindsets of, of
genuine curiosity for the other person and listening to
learn are the, uh, mindsets that you can use
to sort of kick off this process. Along with
that comes the openhearted mindset. The openhearted mindset is
simply saying showing compassion toward the other person, showing
that you care about the other person, showing that
their welfare matters to you. I'm, I'm really happy
that that made your evening so such a, such
a joy, um, or if you're from England, I'm
really sorry that, you know, that just ruined your
evening, um, showing compassion for another person. Is essential
to helping them feel loved because it's the compassion
component that contributes to the feeling of being loved,
so those three are sort of the mindsets that
you can walk into an interaction with. What then
follows and is so critical is what we call
the um is the uh being open mindset, you
know, the mindset of I'm going to respond when
you show reciprocity. Am I going to be closed
up or am I going to really tell you
what's important to me. I'm, am I going to
be genuine and authentic and real about things in
my own experience, um, and that, of course, is
the, is what makes this a dynamic back and
forth kind of interaction, um. Uh, SO you have
to be ready to open up. There are many
people who are good listeners, um, who, but when
it comes to their turn, they, they'll just shut
down, you know, they, they are afraid to reveal
themselves for all the reasons we've talked about, uh,
earlier. Um, SO the important part here is that
when it becomes your opportunity to talk about yourself,
that you that you do genuinely express yourself. Um,
SO that's 4 mindsets, um. The fifth one is
uh one that's captured by the idea that nobody
is one sided, nobody is all good, nobody is
all bad. We all have multiple sides, and if
you judge people solely on the basis of one
aspect of them, you lose the richness and the,
uh, you know, the, the full sense of, of
another, of what another person is about. Uh, AND
this is important not just for other, you know,
the person. So when the other person tells you
something really bad that they did, um, that you
don't judge them harshly, that you, that you ask
yourself, well, gee, maybe there was a good reason
they did that, um, and you know, gee, they,
you know, they may have had a bad day,
but they've had good days too. Um, THOSE things
go along. With uh having the same kind of
of of multiple we call this multiplicity, the same
kind of multiplicity toward yourself, acknowledging that you've probably
done things in your past that you're embarrassed by,
and they don't define you, you have weaknesses, you
have times when you feel vulnerable, and accepting those
and letting the other person see those is just
as important as accepting and recognizing them, recognizing them
in the other person.
Uh, BUT should we be selective in terms of
the people we apply these mindsets with?
Of course, um, you know, should you open up
fully to everybody you come across? No. Um, YOU
know, if you're standing next to someone on, on,
on the bus. Um, YOU know, should you, uh,
tell them about the, you know, the terrible interaction
you had with your boss yesterday? No, I don't
think you should do that. Um, BUT, you know,
not everybody needs or wants to feel loved by
everybody. Um, WE, we tend to reserve the, the.
The necessity, the importance of feeling loved to a
relatively small number of people in our lives. This
is often our romantic partner, this is often our
children, um, this is often family members, this is
often a best friend, but it can be other
people too, um, you know, uh, it can be,
you know, uh, people that one is in a
group with, there's a sense that people, um, even
that one works with often, um, can be in
this situation, and I think. It's important to be
choosy about who one opens up with, um, I
think, but at the same time I would say
there are elements of this process that one can
use universally, um, so, you know, really listening to
learn, for example, is something you can apply with
everybody, um, in, in your life when students come
to talk, uh, to me. You know, I can
show them that I'm really listening with curiosity to
what they're saying, even though it's not a particularly
deep conversation or connection. So I think there are
elements of this that one can use universally, but
I think, you know, in its fullest form, it's
something that one wants to be selective about who
one chooses to use it with, and I guess
the, the, the, you know, the, the complimentary idea
to that. Is the idea that sometimes you're gonna
try these things. And they're not going to work.
Mhm. Well, if they don't work, that tells you
this is not somebody that you're going to feel
loved with, and in that case, um, you know,
move on, find somebody different.
When it comes to opening up specifically, because that's
something that really worries many people, I mean, when
should I open up, when shouldn't I open up,
and to what extent should I open up with,
with other people? I mean, what are the correct
ways and the wrong ways of doing it?
Well, it's easier to describe the wrong ways, so
I'll start there. You know, the wrong way is
to open up about everything in one's life in
the 1st 30 minutes that one is talking to
somebody. Uh, IN the book we call this trauma
dumping, um, you know, the idea that, um, if
you're on a, let's talk about the romantic context,
you're on a first date with someone, you'll talk
about your traumatic childhood. Uh, THAT'S probably a bad
idea. Um, PEOPLE who do this kind of research
like to talk about, um, this in terms of
the peeling of an onion. Um, IF we think
about an onion, there are the superficial outside layers,
and then there are the layers, uh, inside. When
we get to know another person, we're gradually getting,
you know, one layer at a time, deeper and
deeper and deeper. So you want to be doing
two things. You want to be graduated in the
way you do this, meaning you want to slowly
open up, um, at the same time, you also
want to pace yourself according to where the other
person is at. So I might open up a
little. You might open up a little, uh, that
encourages me to open up a little more, that
encourages you to open up a little more. If
I open up a little bit and you don't
return that, that's a signal to me, you know,
hold back, this isn't quite working. Sometimes this unfolds
really fast. Sometimes it may take, you know, weeks,
uh, to, to do this. Um, SO, um, the
important thing. Is to be really mindful of what's
going on in the relationship so that one can
not. Uh, NOT delve too deeply too soon because
that's going to be, um. That's going to be
a real turnoff. We've all had the experience of
sitting on an airplane and having the person sitting
next to us start talking about something horrible, um,
you know, their divorce or something terrible in their
life, and, you know, the immediate reaction to that
is, oh my God, why is this person, why
is this person telling me this? I don't even
know them. Um, SO that doesn't work. It's much
more important to do it in a, in a
slow, gradual kind of way.
So I mean when it comes to sharing information
about ourselves with other people, I imagine that there's
two opposite kinds of mistakes that we can make
and of course depending on the person, the Relationship
we have with them or the relationship we want
to develop with them and the circumstances. I mean,
there are situations or cases where we might be
under sharing and other cases where we might be
oversharing.
That's right. And, and the research that a lot
of people have done shows exactly that, um, you
know, judging. What's the right amount of of opening
up is really it's a social skill. It takes
a lot of experience to learn how to do
that, um, and you know, sometimes one might make
a mistake, um, at it, but definitely, you know,
not opening up enough or opening up too much,
um, can backfire, can backfire, is likely to backfire.
Mhm. So these 5 mindsets we went through just
a few minutes ago, uh, do they apply in
different ways to different kinds of close relationships, like,
for example, romantic relationships, relationships with family, friendships, and
so on, or can we apply them the same
to different kinds of close relationships?
Uh, THAT, that, that's a wonderful question. Um. It,
it may sound like this is something that one
should limit to uh close relationships, but in fact,
I think it's something that can be applied across
the board, um. Certainly listening and curiosity are things
that are absolutely important to almost any kind of
connection in which you want to build a sense
of warmth and a sense of of belonging. Uh,
MULTIPLICITY certainly applies across the board, and interestingly enough,
the openhearted applies across the board, um, as well.
Showing compassion for all the people we encounter in
our lives, not just, um, you know, our romantic
partners. I, I had a colleague once, um, who
really had a reputation of being mean and nasty,
um, he was, you know, he would yell at
secretaries, he would yell at other students. When his
children came in, all of a sudden he was
the sweetest, warmest person you could ever want to
see. So he was practicing open heart but only
toward his children, and as a result, his other
relationships were really, you know, hostile and and and
and not and destructive. Um, THERE'S no reason why
you can't be compassionate towards uh most of the
people that you encounter in your life. Now, um,
the one where this gets a little tricky is
the one about opening up about yourself, uh, the
sharing mindset, um. It's not necessarily appropriate to share
about every aspect of your life with everybody you
come into contact with. Um, ONE of the things
I've been impressed by is, uh, when, uh, football
players talk about how they feel about their teammates,
and they talk about how much they love them.
Um, NOW, does that mean that they feel the
same way towards their teammates that they feel towards
their, their romantic partners? I don't think so. I
think it means that in a limited domain, they
feel like they can share their thoughts and feelings
in, in a fully and authentic way. So you
can share how you feel about how the game
is going, you can share how you feel about
the coach, you can share about things that might
make your workout more effective. Um, COLLEAGUES at work
can share how they feel about work and share
about parts of their ideas that they're struggling with
and parts that they think are, are, are good.
So I think the sharing mindset sometimes is more
domain limited, um, than some of the others. But
the others I think apply across the board, you
know, you, you can be a good listener and
you can be openhearted towards your barista when you're
getting coffee.
Yeah. So earlier we've talked about individual factors. How
about culture? Can culture play a role in people's
ability to feel loved?
Um, Yeah, that's, that's a very interesting question, and
there's a lot of work going on right now
that's trying to get at that question. I don't
think culture changes the fact that people want to
feel loved. I do think that culture can play
a major role in how that need is expressed
and how that need is fulfilled. So in certain
cultures, for example, um, emotional openness is discouraged. Um,
COMPASSION is expressed in a very, the openhearted mindset
is expressed in a very different way, you know,
in, in, in, in the Western world, we express
the openhearted mindset by giving big hugs, by being
very affectionate, by kissing someone, and, you know, we're
very out front about it. In East Asian cultures,
people are much more reserved about that, uh, you
know, you would never meet somebody on the street
and, uh, you know, and give them a big
hug unless it was your sister or someone, uh.
So people are, people are still expressing compassion and
and openheartedness toward each other, but they're not doing
it in such a um a a visible, um,
expressive kind of way. So it's much more subtle,
um, sharing, I think, uh, comes out a little
different too, you know, in an East Asian culture,
being too open about difficult things in one's lives.
Might be perceived as burdensome to the group as
as problematic for the group, and so one must
be much subtler about the way that uh those
kinds of needs are expressed. So I think there
are differences in the way these things come out.
I think, I think the general ideas are the
same, but the specifics can often uh look different.
But does, uh, uh, uh, that does not necessarily
mean that people from those cultures because they are
not so expressive that they feel less
loved. Uh, uh, I don't think it means that
they feel less loved. In fact, uh, there's some
reason to believe that they may feel more loved.
Um, um, THERE'S some work that we did many
years ago in, uh, Hong Kong. That showed that
people were much less outgoing about their emotions in
in conversation, but at the same time they felt
more understood by the people, by their families in
particular, and the reason is that because is that
in the Western world we feel like we, if
we don't, if we're not expressing it all the
time, it may not be real. Whereas in Hong
Kong, we think it was part of people's lives,
uh, and people just feel known and, and valued
by, by their families. So, so, so it can
often be more of of an implicit sense in
those cultures.
Um, HOW about, uh, gender differences, because there's these
gender stereotypes that we have that, I mean, uh,
men, uh, uh, feel less need to feel loved,
that women feel more need to feel loved, that,
um, women are. More emotional, men are less emotional.
I mean, is that really true and that does
that really translate into the need to feel loved?
Uh, YEAH, you know, that that's a, that's an
age-old question and, and people have been doing research
on this for years and years and years. Um,
I don't think there's any question that the need
to feel loved is important to men and to
women, um. Is there a difference on average? I
don't know, but if there is a difference, it's
likely to be very small. Now, having said that.
I think it's also very clear that women, in
at least in the Western world, feel loved to
a much greater extent than men do. You know,
there's a lot of interesting research about midlife men
living lives of what's called quiet desperation. The idea
that they don't feel loved as much as they
want to, you know, why, why is suicide so
much more prevalent among men than among women, and
I think one of the reasons for that is
precisely what you mentioned, the idea. That women are
much more likely to engage in these 5 in
conversations using these 5 mindsets than men are. Men,
you know, men are worried about expressing vulnerabilities to
other men for fear of being exploited. Men have
adopted social norms that you're not supposed to open
up, that you're supposed to show strength, um, that
and. One of the problems in that is that
um men start to feel that other people don't
know them. Um, ONE of the most interesting phenomena
that I've noticed over the years is, um, if
you ask a woman. Who's your best friend, who
really knows you well, um, who would you go
to for emotional support? Roughly speaking, about half of
women will name, uh, their romantic partner, their husband.
If you talk to men, they will all name
their wife. Um, AND, and furthermore, if you ask,
even if you ask men, um, in their 50s
and sixties who's your best friend, they'll name somebody
from high school. Um, YOU know, men develop close
relationships, uh, later in life to a far, far
less extent than women do, and that may be
one of the reasons why, you know, there's really
interesting work on bereavement. That shows that. Um, AFTER
the death of a spouse, men are far more
likely to remarry and to remarry sooner than women
are, and there are a lot of explanations for
that, but one of them is that men are
looking for a source of support, a source of
someone that they can have emotional support from, whereas
women are, are much more likely are relatively more
likely to get that from other women as well.
Mhm. So, one question that I think is very
relevant to our current context, do you think that
we can find real connection with AI chatbots?
Uh, THAT'S, you know, that's such a hot topic
right now, you know, every, everybody's thinking about, I
was just at a conference and there were like
5 different papers on that topic, um. The, the
short story I think is that um. Chatbots are
very good at providing validation and affirm affirmation. One
of the reasons chatbots are so good at it
is that they've been trained on the research that
we're talking about. So, you know, a chatbot knows
how to be validating. It doesn't have its own
needs that might get in the way, and it
can tell you, wow, that was so important, you
know, I can see how hard that was for
you. They can do that easily. Now Somewhere down
the road. You're going to realize. That that's not
a voluntary choice that the chatbot made, that it's
something that it was programmed to do. So, you
know, if I tell you about a problem I'm
having and you tell me about how much compassion
you have for that, and you really do that
convincingly. I, uh, my mindset is Ricardo really cares
about me. Or at least that Ricardo's a really
caring person. What's my inference, if I think about
it, about the chatbot? It's, oh, there's an algorithm
that did that. Now it does it really well
and we're all, we all, our brains are primed
to, to, you know, to respond to that simulated
content in a really strong way. So I think
the answer is in the short term. If one
is having a difficult time and other people are
not meeting one's needs, I think, I think they
play, they can play a valuable role. In the
long term, I think it can't work, um, because
in the long term, there is a case going
on in the US now where a woman is
trying to marry her chatbot, uh, legally marry, and
it's, and I don't know what the courts are
going to decide, but it's an interesting kind of
question because, you know, because the, the chatbot isn't
going to, the chatbot isn't going to start telling
you about its own problems and give you a
chance to respond. Unless it makes stuff up. And
you know, it might make stuff up, but then
you realize you're giving, you're giving feedback to something
that's not real, um, so at some point it
becomes, it becomes false. It's like, you know, if
you're really hungry, eating some candy may satisfy your
hunger in the short term, but does it provide
a full nutritional meal? No, you can't live on
candy. Um, SO, in the short term, yes, and,
and, and as a bridge, and even as a
teaching tool, by the way, um, you know, for
people who are really not good at this, uh,
for example, um, You know, individuals with learning disabilities
or or autism who really don't know how to
do these kind of interactions, it can be very
useful as a training tool. But I think ultimately
it has to be transferred to a a real
live human being.
So I have one last question then in the
context of your book and the topics we talked
about here today, um, what do you think about
polyamory and other types of consensual non-monogamous relationships?
Uh, ANOTHER interesting question, uh, and timely question, um.
In principle, I see no reason why all of
the things we talk about can't go on in
polyamorous relationships as well. There's some preliminary evidence for
that. There's not a lot of good research on
consensual non-monogamy yet. There's some research, and it suggests
that. Um, IF those kind of relationships are done
openly and honestly, um, there's no reason why they
have to be any different, um, than the kinds
of relationship we, we talked about. Now, And and
one of the most interesting sets of findings for
me is how. Polyamorous relationships can be satisfying and
fulfilling and committed at the same time that there's
a good amount of jealousy, um, you know, and
being open about the jealousy is an essential component
to making them work. Um, NOW, but this only
works. The key word here is consensual. This only
works if all of the people who are participating
genuinely feel this way, um, and, and there's some
evidence that sometimes people who are committed, who are
participating in polyamorous relationships are doing so because they
feel pressured, uh, by their partner to do that,
and in those instances, um, it's not going to
work.
Yeah, I mean, do you, there are, I've heard
criticisms from people who are, I mean, I don't
want to say they are necessarily against polyamory and
nonconsensual monogamy, but they criticize them where they say
that, for example, they or they argue that in
Polyamory relationships, the kind of connection that you can
build with people, it can never be as deep
as it is in a monogamous long-term relationship. I
mean, do you think that there could be something
to that?
Well, you know, what I would say is that
that's an empirical question, you know, that we need
to do the research to test that out. So
far, the research that I've seen says that that's
not true. Um, uh, YOU know, I'll point out
that many monogamous romantic relationships really struggle with closeness,
really struggle, you know, uh, you know, the divorce
rate is still hovering around, you know, 47, 48%
in, in most parts of the, of the, of
the Western world at least. Um, SO, you know,
I would say it's not working so well in
monogamous relationships, uh. You know, it's too soon to
tell, but you know, there's no a priori reason
to think that polyamorous relationships are going to be
any more problematic than uh monogamous relationships, to be
sure there's more going on, there's more that has
to be negotiated, there's more, you know, you spend
time, you know, with one person, well, is the
other person going to be jealous, um, that. That
can be problematic, but, you know, the, the question
is going to be, do, uh, polyamorous relationships endure
over time that are fulfilling at the same rate
as monogamous relationships, and I, I think there's no
reason to think it's going that they're going to
be any worse, um, if, if, if they're voluntary
and, and truly um open with with each other.
Mhm. OK, great. So the book is again, How
to Feel Love, The Five Mindsets that get you
more of what Matters Most, and of course I
will be leaving a link to it in the
description of the interview. And Doctor, Doctor Ray, thank
you so much for taking the time to come
on the show. It's been a fascinating conversation.
Oh, it's been a pleasure to talk to you,
Ricardo. Thank you for having me.
Hi guys, thank you for watching this interview until
the end. If you liked it, please share it,
leave a like and hit the subscription button. The
show is brought to you by Enlights, Learning and
Development done differently. Check their website at lights.com and
also please consider supporting the show on Patreon or
PayPal. I would also like to give a huge
thank you to my main patrons and PayPal supporters,
Perergo Larsson, Jerry Mulleran, Frederick Sundo, Bernard Seaz Olaf,
Alex, Adam Cassel, Matthew Whittingberrd, Arnaud Wolf, Tim Hollis,
Eric Elena, John Connors, Philip Forrest Connolly. Then Dmitri
Robert Windegerru Inai Zu Mark Nevs, Colin Holbrookfield, Governor,
Michel Stormir, Samuel Andre, Francis Forti Agnun, Svergoro, and
Hal Herzognon, Michel Jonathan Labrarinth, John Yardston, and Samuel
Cerri, Hines, Mark Smith, John Ware, Tom Hammel, Sardusran,
David Sloane Wilson, Yasilla Dezara Romain Roach, Diego Londono
Correa. Yannik Punter DaRosmani, Charlotte Blis Nicole Barbaro, Adam
Hunt, Pavlostazevski, Alec Baka Madison, Gary G. Alman, Semov,
Zal Adrian Yei Poltontin, John Barboza, Julian Price, Edward
Hall, Edin Bronner, Douglas Fry, Franco Bartolotti, Gabriel P
Scortez or Suliliski, Scott Zachary Fish, Tim Duffyani Smith,
and Wisman. Daniel Friedman, William Buckner, Paul Georg Jarno,
Luke Lovai, Georgios Theophannus, Chris Williamson, Peter Wolozin, David
Williams, Dio Costa, Anton Ericsson, Charles Murray, Alex Shaw,
Marie Martinez, Coralli Chevalier, Bangalore atheists, Larry D. Lee
Junior. Old Eringbon. Esterri, Michael Bailey, then Spurber, Robert
Grassy, Zigoren, Jeff McMahon, Jake Zul, Barnabas Raddix, Mark
Kempel, Thomas Dovner, Luke Neeson, Chris Story, Kimberly Johnson,
Benjamin Galbert, Jessica Nowicki, Linda Brendan, Nicholas Carlson, Ismael
Bensleyman. George Ekoriati, Valentine Steinmann, Per Crawley, Kate Van
Goler, Alexander Ebert, Liam Dunaway, BR, Massoud Ali Mohammadi,
Perpendicular, Jannes Hetner, Ursula Guinov, Gregory Hastings, David Pinsov,
Sean Nelson, Mike Levin. And Josnecht. A special thanks
to my producers Iar Webb, Jim Frank Lucas Stink,
Tom Venneden, Bernard Curtis Dixon, Benedict Mueller, Thomas Trumbull,
Catherine and Patrick Tobin, John Carlo Montenegro, Al Nick
Cortiz, and Nick Golden, and to my executive producers,
Matthew Lavender, Sergio Quadrian, Bogdan Kanis, and Rosie. Thank
you for all.